los chilenos decidieron reemplazar la
constitución de redactada durante el
régimen militar de augusto pinochet y lo
harán a través de una convención
constitucional con 155 ciudadanos que
serán elegidos en una próxima jornada
electoral prevista para abril de 2021
cientos de personas se tomaron la plaza
italia rebautizada como plaza dignidad
durante las manifestaciones para
celebrar
incluso desde antes que cerraran las
urnas y los manifestantes comenzaron a
llegar a la icónica plaza epicentro de
las marchas iniciadas en octubre de 2019
que desencadenaron en la convocatoria a
este plebiscito
el presidente sebastián piñera calificó
la jornada como un triunfo de la
democracia ahora la constitución nos ha
dividido
a partir de hoy todos debemos colaborar
para que la nueva constitución sea el
gran marco de unidad de estabilidad y de
futuro y es que la jornada supera cifras
históricas de participación podría ser
una de las más altas desde que el voto
empezó a ser voluntario en 2012 la
votación se desarrolló en medio de
medidas de seguridad para prevenir la
propagación del coi 19 con un horario
específico para los mayores de 60 el uso
obligatorio de máscaras y cada votante
debía llevar su propio bolígrafo en un
domingo cualquiera un domingo histórico
hoy día es el día en que chile
literalmente escribe que se despertó
esto un proceso que lleva un año
y hoy día es el bien que finalmente
podemos ver es aquí ahora empiezan las
campañas de los miembros de la
convención constituyente que empezarían
a trabajar en mayo de 2021